こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
みなさんはドラマとか
演技の映像とかってよく見たことあると思います
例えばですね映画のね、ちょっと感動するシーンとか
いろんなねぇ、シーンがあるんですよ
怖いシーン、面白いシーン、笑えるシーン
様々なシーンがあると思うんですけども
まぁ僕もね、そういうちょっと
映像を作るってことをしてるんで
これからそういうシーンのこととかをちょっと
学んでいきたいと思ってるわけなんです
なんで今日はちょっと
ある１つのシーンにしぼって
そのシーンの中で
何をして、何を変えて
どういう表情でやって、どういう服装でやって
どういう雰囲気とかでやればいいのか
いろんなね、条件が
挟まって
挟まらねぇわ
いろんな条件が絡み合って
はじめてその良い映像作品とか
シーンっていうのができると
僕は思ってるわけなんですよ
なんで、今日はある１シーンを使って
このシーンで様々なそのシチュエーションとか
表情、服装、顔の動きとか
いろんなものをチェンジしてって
シーンによって何が一番大事なのかていうのをね
この動画を通して皆さんもね、僕もねちょっと
学べればいいなと思っております
参考にするシーンはこちらです
どうぞ
おれは飯田てんぷらのすけ
サッカー部のキャプテンだ
ある日、うちのエースの田中が部活をやめた
メンバーのいない俺たちサッカー部は
部員不足の危機だった
おい田中！
飯田？
お前...なんでサッカー部やめた！
お前には関係ねぇだろ...
ふざけんじゃねぇ！
なにすんだよ!
お前のせいで先生が試合に出てるんだぞ
そんな...
先生！
それでこそ田中だ
じゃあこれをねちょっとこう
いろいろ変えてみてね
いろんなシーンどうなるかやってみようと思います
どうぞ
おい田中！
飯田...
お前...なんでサッカー部やめたぁ！
お前には関係ねぇだろ
ふざけんじゃねぇ！
なにすんだよ！
お前のせいで先生が試合に出てるんだぞ
そんな...
先生
それでこそ田中だ
おい田中ぁ！
飯田...
お前...なんでサッカー部やめた！
お前には関係ねぇだろ
ふざけんじゃねぇ！
なにすんだよ!
お前のせいで先生が試合に出てるんだぞ
そんな...
先生
それでこそ田中だ
はっはっ！
はは
おい田中ぁ！
飯田？
お前...なんでサッカー部やめた！
お前には関係ねぇだろ
ふざけんじゃねぇ！
なにすんだよ！
お前のせいで先生が試合に出てるんだぞ
そんな
先生
それでこそ田中だ
おい田中ぁ！
飯田？
お前...なんでサッカー部やめた！
お前には関係ねぇだろ
ふざけんじゃねぇ！
なにすんだよぉ
お前のせいで先生が試合に出てるんだぞ
そんな...
先生！
それでこそ田中だ
おい田中ぁ！
飯田？
お前ぇ...なんでサッカー部やめたぁ！
お前には関係ねぇだろ
ふざけんじゃねぇ！
なにすんだよ！
お前のせいで先生が試合に出てるんだぞぉ
そんなぁ...
先生！
それでこそ田中だ